قرار مجموعه السبعه والاتحاد الاوروبي
واستراليا فرض سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي قد
دخل حيز التنفيذ في الخامس من ديسمبر
الجاري واتفقت الاطراف على ان لا يتجاوز
سعر برميل النفط الروسي المنقول بحرا 60
دولارا الاتفاق الغربي واجهه صعوبات حيث
كانت دول مثل بولندا ولتانيا
اقل من 30 دولارا يذكر ان النفط الروسي
يلبي قرابه 10 ونصف المئه من الطلب
العالمي وكان قرار فرض سقفا لاسعار النفط
الروسي قد واجهت من ارتفاع حاد للاسعار
العالميه وتتراوح وتكلفه انتاج النفط
الروسي بين 17 الى 30 دولارا للبرميل بدون
فرد سقفا للاسعار كانت توقعات تشير الى ان
ارباح صادرات النفط والغاز الروسيه قد تصل
الى اكثر من 320 مليار دولار قبل ايام قال
اجسام نوفاك النائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي
للتلفزيون الرسمي قال ان روسيا قد تقلص
انتاجها من النفط ما بين خمسه الى سبعه
بالمئه او الى عام 2023 اي ما يتراوح بين
500,000 و700,000 برميلا يوميا
انه الينا اذا من برلين
الخبير في شؤون الطاقه والاستاذ بمدرسته
هرتي العليا
برلين اهلا بك دكتور
نفذ الرئيس الروسي اذن الافلام
السياسي كيف يمكن ان يتوقع تداعياته على
الدول الغربيه
المعنيه بوقت هذا الانتاج
مساء الخير شكرا على الاستضافه في حقيقه
الامر انا لا استطيع رؤيه اذا ما كان لهذا
القرار سيكون له اي تاثيرا على الاتحاد
الاوروبي الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ الخامس من
ديسمبر فرضا عقوبات قاسيه للغايه على
النفط الروسي الاتحاد الروسيه
عن طريق البحر وفي الخامس من فبراير لانه
يتلقى المزيد من ايام مشتقات محسنه وخاصه
الديزل من روسيا بالتالي بالتاكيد هذه
الدول هذه الدول ايضا لديها تقوم بتطبيق
السقفيه على اسعار النفط عن طريق الرفض
السماح لاي شركه اوروبيه تقوم بتامين
السفن وهذه معظم السفن في العالم التي
تنقل النفط بان تنقل اي نفط لنا روسي ما
لم يقوموا بنقله الى دوله اخرى تحترمها
هذا السقف بالتالي لن يكون له اي تاثير
على وحقيقه ان يكون له اي تاثير على الصين
او الهند او على تركيا وهي الدول الاساسيه
الاخرى التي تاخذ النفط الروسيدي ان تلك
الدول تقوم بدفع للنفط الروسي اا اقل من
السقف الموضوع السؤال هو من اللي هي
التاثيرات المستقبليه في الوقت الذي ينخفض
فيه السقف الاسعار او ارتفعت الاسعار
او تتاثر الاسواق العالميه اسواق النفط
العالميه فيما يتعلق بها القرار
الرئاسيه الروسي
اكشن في حقيقه الامر لن يكون له اي تاثير
الصين الهند وتركيا هي الدول الاساسيه
التي تتلقى اكثر قدر ممكن من النفط هي لن
تتمكن من اخذ كل النفط الذي باستطاعته
التي لا تستطيع روسيا بيعه الى الدول
الاوروبيه بالتالي هذا سيقلل ويؤثر على
روسيا بشكل كبير منذ خمس منذ ديسمبر وبعد
ذلك الاسبوع وحسب البنانات من بلوم بارك
فان روسيا
وشحنات ان نفت في البالطيق وفي الجانب
الاوروبيين خفضت بنسبه 50 دينار بالتالي
روسيا هي اصبحت ترس الكميات اقل بنسبه 50%
في تلك المناطق او الوجهات لا ان يبدو كان
الامر ما قام به السيد بوتن قال اننا
لنبيعه الى اي شخص يقوم بتطبيق السقف على
الاسعار هذا الامر قد تم فرضه عليه وهو
الان يبدوه وكانه يبدو يظهر انه كلكم
خيارات ويملك حق الرد على ذلك القرار يملك
خيارات وهذا ما تتحدث عنه ايضا موسكو لكن
من هو المتاثر الاكبر اعلم بانك قلت بان
هذه الدول الغربيه لن تاثر من جراء هذا
القرار لكن من هو
الخاسر الاكبر جراء هذا المرسوم الرئاسي
او هذا القرار السياسي الروسي
اعتقد ان الخاسر الاكبر هي روسيا حقا
روسيا تخسر بشكل
الاسواق في اسيا في الهند والصين وتركيا
لكن الاسعار منخفضه للغايه هي تبيع همم
بنسبه 25 همم دولارا ربما اقل للبرميل من
هذا يضع قيودا على روسيا
مستقبلا
فان الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول السبعه الكبرى
تلتقي مره اخرى في فبراير وستقرر اذا ما
ست- تخفي تقوم بتخفيض هذا فحتى ولم توافق
الهجره الصين على تخفي لكنهم يستفيدون من
هذا الوضع سيقولون لروسيا هنا لك سقف على
الاسعار عليكم ان تبيعوا نفتكم لنا باسعار
اقل بالتالي هم يجبرون روسيا على البيع
باسعار اقل واقل وهذه خطه اداره بايدن هم
يتوقعوا هذا الامر وتوقعوا قيام الهند
والصين بالقيام بذلك حتى ولم يقوم
بالتوقيع
واحترام سقف الاسعار لكنه واقعيين سيتبعون
هذا السقف اشكرك دكتور توماس اودعنا
الخبير في شؤون الطاقه والاستاذ بمدرسه
حرتي العليا برلين